so die nächste frage höre ich auch
anderer und zwar von unicorn hast du
derzeit eine freunde willkommen bei
einer neuen video und zu hab ich mir
gedacht es ist wirklich mal wieder an
der zeit ein neues format haus zu
bringen was dann wirklich mal regelmäßig
kommt und das gibt halt leute also jeder
youtuber anderen die ab und zu mal
fragen und das sind dann halt so fragen
wie welcher ist zurzeit lieblingsfilm
gehört ihr auch eigentlich dazu mal halb
fragen zu beantworten und bei mir geht's
heute halt auch darum erstmal fragen zu
beantworten aber nicht so langweilige
fragen wir hier unten oder oben wie
unten am titel bestimmt schon gelesen
habt heißt das ganze alex privat und
deswegen geht es auch um fragen die euch
wirklich interessieren dich wirklich
andauernd bekomme wie alle youtuber
andauernd bekommen aber darauf
eigentlich gar nicht eingehen ach ja was
heute auch wieder ganz wichtig ist wenn
ihr bock habt dass ich davon wirklich
mehr mache dann schreibt einen kommentar
oder saß auf jeden fall noch nach oben
da dann weiß ich bescheid
und dann gibt es natürlich auch so
schnell wie möglich die zweite folge und
ja ich werde zu ende war so ein bisschen
meine meinung äußern wie ich halt zu der
frage stehe
und ich will ganz klar band los geht die
erste frage kommt von leer um 14 oder so
und zwar fragt sie lieber single oder
vergeben ist eine frage die ich schon
zig milliarden bekommen habe und meine
antwort darauf ist man kann halt nicht
entscheiden wie es kommt wenn es passt
dann passt es und wenn es nicht passt
dann passt es halt nicht deswegen kann
ich jetzt nicht sagen single ist besser
oder beziehung ist besser juno nächste
fahrt kommt von 237 kilometer
unterstrich und zwar fragt sie oder er
keine ahnung charakter oder aussehen
jeder junge der sagt ich bin dort
charakter was geht gar nicht ohne scheiß
es soll auch nicht oberflächlich klingen
aber jeder jugend geht auch nach dem
aussehen man geht natürlich ein erstmal
nach dem aussehen zur ist halt so wenn
diese person wo man halt vor eventuell
mehr nach dem aussehen gegangen ist
einen guten charakter
seit man wahrscheinlich länger zusammen
als wenn die scheiße ist es logisch ganz
einfach beantwortet nächste frage ohne
scheiß die nächste frage wurde bestimmt
schon um die 1000 mal gestellt und zwar
fragt seminar 1 wärst du je mit einem
zusammen also als erstes ich sage immer
lieber zuschauer und als zweites keine
ahnung ein zuschauer von mir ist auch
ein ganz normaler mensch und wenn es
passt dann passt ist man kann doch nicht
sagen
du guckst beide videos du bist scheiße
in dich oder dich darf ich nicht als
meine freundin haben keinen sinn
deswegen hört bitte auf mir diese frage
andauern zu stellen jeweils einmal die
antwort und wieso sollte das nicht gehen
schreibt ihr in die kommentare warum
dürfte das nicht geben so die nächste
frage höre ich auch anders und zwar
fragt der unicorn hast du derzeit eine
freundin und wenn ja kannst du machen
eingriffen tag mit ihr machen ich hatte
ja gesagt auch wenn ich eine freundin
hab ich mache halt beziehung nicht mehr
öffentlich also ich koste kein foto aber
ich kann euch sagen ich habe jetzt keine
freude alles ist gut und girlfriend es
sich auch nicht nochmal machen so die
nächste frage lautet wie stehst du zu
dem thema rauchen und brauchst du selber
wie zudem lasse stehe wenn jemand meint
immer trauen dann soll rauchen
man fängt ja meistens so mit 15 an um
dann cool zu sein und dann geht's halt
nicht mehr oben ich persönlich auch
nicht ich habe auch nicht vor damit
anzufangen weil das mega sinnlos ist und
stelle mich mal fahre ich halt jetzt
mein 15 angefangen zu rauchen so ich bin
jetzt 17
und ich hätte alle zwei tage fünf euro
dafür bezahlt dann wäre ich so bei 3000
euro jetzt oder so ich weiß noch gar
nicht wie man so sein geld verschenken
kann es gibt viel schönere dinge die man
leider keine ahnung geht in urlaub oder
so aber ich weiß also ich stehe da halt
so zu so die nächste frage ist auch
lustig und zwar hast du schon mal einen
korb von einem mädchen kassiert ich weiß
gar nicht er habe ich bestimmt schon mal
aber durch halt nicht so wirklich ich
kann mich nicht mehr daran erinnern so
richtig glauben habe ich schon bestimmt
mal also halt nicht so krass aber ein
bisschen halt nicht so krass wie zum
beispiel wenn ich abends war ich bin
also ich sehe dauern so jungs auch noch
ein
und noch ein also so ist das bei mir
nicht aber habe ich auch schon mal
ich hatte ja am anfang schon gesagt wenn
ihr wirklich bock habe dass ich hier von
den regelmäßig was raushauen was halt
was euch wirklich interessiert und nicht
so langweilige fragen geht nach oben
oder wie gesagt hätten kommentare keine
ahnung
ansonsten abonniere ich war ganz so war
das eingeblendete oben rechts geht's
weiter oben links ist kurzweilig fast
das war auf jeden fall jungs alleine
vier jungs welchen check ist auf jeden
fall ab und wir sehen uns nächsten
montag wieder da bin ich leider schon im
urlaub aber es kommt auf jeden fall
trotzdem video abchecken dann und band